il ya un extrait qui a fait énormément
parler on va remettre à l'extrait et
vous avez vous dire si vous comprenez
voilà ce lever de bouclier sur les
réseaux sociaux ou si vous trouvez que
c'est exagéré ou nous dit la vérité
bien entendu ici et on vous a posé la
question on revoit l'extrait c'était un
humoriste donc deux comédiens qui
s'appelle pablo mira qui a fait qu'il y
des tweets de haters et ton qui a pris
fin en banlieue lui l'accent montlieu
voilà regardez regardez je vais aller
aider la daronne en cuisine les frères
hésitez pas aidé vodafone pendant le
ramadan là je vais chercher le sel parce
qu'il est trop pour elle dans le placard
par exemple après je retourne jouer à la
play shalom chaleur je sais pas mais
qu'elle chacal ça oui de toute évidence
alors y'en a qui ont été choqués il y en
a que tout simplement pas aimé la blague
il y en a aussi qui ont défendu pablo
mira alors malek délégué c'est vous qui
avez été le l'instigateur mine de rien
c'est parce qu'il a une influence celui
ci n'a rien à craindre
voilà sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est
vous qui avez utile pour un des premiers
chocs et pourquoi le j'ai été
personnellement heurter par par la
séquence alors contrairement à tout ce
que j'ai pu lire sur les réseaux j'ai vu
la séquence dans son intégralité
oui il prend un accent pour sa télé
tweet tilly dans sa chronique a pas de
problème cependant la danseuse dans le
tweet en question
premièrement la caricature ne s'est pas
contre mais quand c'est drôle
là pour le coup ce n'était pas drôle sur
son plateau j'ai pas vu grand monde
rigolait sur le nôtre j'ai vu personne
rigoler ensuite cette fixette permanente
sur la banlieue mois sur le de moins en
banlieue j'y suis né j'y habite je vis
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui se lèvent
tous les matins pour aller bosser des
gens qui se lèvent tous les matins pour
aller étudier
il ya des gens qui se battent contre
toutes les discriminations à l'adresse
au nom à l'origine et qu'on les réduise
à cet accent là alors - sa mère malade
il ya plein de gens aussi échoué dit
voilà je ne fais aussi et l'avocate
boudreau qui lisent ce exagéré alors
dans ce cas là on voulait faire du
mouron un plomb non maintenant parce que
là c'est bon tu as entendu jean michel
oui moi je trouve qu'il faut arrêter de
se choquer de tous ouais ouais moi j'ai
pas été choqué et ce n'est pas drôle ça
c'est nul
et quand c'est pas drôle ça tombe à plat
et du coup ça prête mais bon voilà bien
qui tous les jours deux rouleaux
et bien sûr d'accord mais les accents
excuse moi quand s'est moqué pendant
trente ans des belges ont fait passer
pour des cons personne ne s'est levé la
levée de boucliers en lisant arrêté
après c'est sûr la banlieue c'est moi je
vous dire après moi ce qu'ils voient là
c'est que juste cet accent de banlieue
on le faisait en 2002 quoi cela s'est
fini c'est trop ça voilà ça c'est ici
voilà c'est chaud qui s'est passé ici
c'est mort oui jimmy mohammed vi jean
michel tu parles d'accent met l'accent
des banlieues ça n'existe pas et oui bah
oui ça aller en banlieue tous les jours
voir cet axe en existe par ifs et tous
ceux qui pensent que ça existe sont les
mêmes qui voit la banlieue au travers de
reportages de ghajar de la villardière
éléments et qui pensent que la banlieue
c'est une zone de non droit donc ce
n'était pas drôle d'accord mais moi ça
me saoule d'autant plus que quotidien
c'est un peu les donneurs de leçons de
service c'est un peu cette élite
parisienne qui explique ce que doit être
la france ce que doit être le monde les
bobos qui explique aux bobos voilà ce
qu'on fait et nous notre côté ici on est
les ploucs de services qui font rire
tout le monde je suis désolé moi souvent
ludiques ou jimmy choo compact et
médecins qu'est ce que tu vas faire
sauter pmp mais je suis désolé la parole
est nettement plus libre et vous donner
notamment dans les autres émissions la
parole à tout le monde et vous humilier
personne parce que là je suis désolé ça
a blessé les gens en banlieue on ne
parle pas comme ça oui mais donc
d'accord c'est pas marrant mais en plus
ça blesse et chant ça blesse moi ça me
saoule jimmy ouellet
ils sont ils sont moi à mon sens ils ont
été trop lents gimmi c'est très intime
d'une caricature évidemment oui c'est
sarah comme ça mais en belgique pourquoi
tout le monde parle de augsburg des
frites ou neuf fois on n'a pas tant
masculine jean michel isabelle mme
isabelle moi qui ai mis du temps je suis
entièrement d'accord avec jean michel se
touchent la blague n'était pas drôle non
mais plutôt fort maladroit mais que
localisation
macquarie aussi alors tu vois on parle
pas du tout comme ça j'étais avec joe
choqué a choqué 24% pas choquer 76%
mes parents étaient les spectateurs sont
parus ce qu'il faut c'est de jean-michel
voilà on va passer à un autre sujet les
chéris mais voilà c'est important après
que s'ouvrira ajouté juste juste
rapidement c'est pas parce que ça m'a
heurté parce qu'on m'a aussi dit oh tu
appelles à la censure etc
je dis juste que ce n'était pas drôle
que ça m'a heurté il a le droit de le
faire je moi je sue le censeur de
personnes c'est tout ce que je sais
c'est non menace tous les jours